I live a glamorous life why Lady Gaga is
a perfect co-chair for the 2019 Met Gala
and it's camp theme this year's theme of
the gala is based off of the 1964 essay
by Susan Sontag
notes on Camp sonntag explains the
essence of camp is quote love of the
unnatural of artifice and exaggeration
the Born This Way singer has only been
two fashions biggest night twice once in
2015
rocking a black and white voluminous
kimono style dress embellished with
feathers by Balenciaga and in 2016 when
she looked like a total rock star in
this pantsless Versace moment with wild
hair and sky high-heeled boots camp is
going all the way and going too far with
fashion which Gaga is no stranger to
Gaga famously rocked a raw flank steak
dress during the 2010 MTV Video Music
Awards and paired the ensemble with a
matching hairpiece and heels all
designed by Frank Fernandez the look is
now on display at the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame I never thought I'd be asking
cher to hold my meat purse joke they a
drag just be a queen don't be a drag
just be a queen and she arrived at the
2011 Grammy Awards in an egg although in
recent years Gaga's fashion has evolved
we know she'll pull out all the stops
this year as the theme is a nod to her
over-the-top fashion of the past
I feel so humbled and honored
it's wonderful when you get to work with
designers and they make custom looks for
you